okay on d4 again I had a really nice
game with a bank Oh last time so get it
again let's see what outline opponent
comes up this time okay actually the
same I wasn't aware that this is still
still popular I saw this some this idea
while ago I've tournament as the idea to
maybe play even six later is six and
after capturing maybe if d5 so combine
them the queenside play with them play
in the center
and this is always a bit of a concern
for white to have the green year in the
same mount diagonal and now even he
doesn't cover a3 anymore with the Queen
so maybe this is some lessons right now
yeah but ok d5 this look is some quite
well positioned here
okay what happens now I'd like to of
course them something like d 495 would
be nice
so I ok always has his checks at least
at least maybe they are even more more
dangerous options here very complicated
yeah let's go for this anyway okay play
something entirely different grade
calculation ok now cancel of course also
possible 97 yeah of course
very difficult to play do I want to play
95 to cover this yeah maybe this might
also allow on 95 later I didn't want to
play a passive move to cover c7 so
I don't know I have my doubts about this
position for black of course that it
looks it looks a bit shaky somehow okay
but does this threaten anything here
maybe okay I need to get out of this pin
not much choice maybe yeah of course so
now what I could play rook a false could
be one idea
but I could also just play ruki ate it
sits at the moment it is some it is at
the edges in the Pena but of course you
don't want to retrieve this route from
the F fire poor just insanely
complicated this position
I'm just take this two times look on 86
of course I completely forget about this
forgot about this so what does he do now
funny I was thinking just Bishop t2 or
something but this is hanging twice
twice so
maybe needs to do something completely
insane like Queen takes d5 and then the
97 or something I'm not sure I don't see
a move
yeah he doesn't see one neither thing
just letting the clock run down really
strange yeah but this line is is so
complicated with all the pieces playing
in the center very easy to to play bad
news yeah the stripper just winning outs
I have 95 now 95 yeah Knight f3 to come
yeah just d3 maybe what's your forms if
all time warning yeah it should be
everything wins ok I'm night see three
maybe four yeah and then i have three
well
King out one I can take Queen takes
Queen takes and queen h1 mate white
forfeits on time yeah i was completely
blind here i said i didn't see it does
it take to time so so 96's is just bad
here no no idea i cannot analyze this
position can just quickly ask the
computer just to get some idea as usual
it gives all 0 hey what does he want to
play out this window is strangely setup
we should before he wants to play yeah
okay this is no humans you have no idea
just to complicate it okay